Like I've been saying, 2026 is getting
crazy. Buckle up your seat belts. This
is a wild ride. The government is now
saying that there are military programs
that are abducting people and putting
them in cages and breeding them with
aliens. You heard that right. I didn't
stutter. This is real deal. This is
mainstream media news. When I say this
is real deal, I'm not saying that I
believe this stuff. I I don't believe
the government. I don't believe the
news, but this is what they are
propagating to the public. This is what
they want you to believe. Remember that
the mainstream media is controlled. So,
anything that comes out in mainstream
media is because this is what they want
you to believe or this is the
information that they want you to have.
This is the mainstream narrative. Always
question the mainstream narrative. I
don't care if it's a major event or if
it's that aliens are here. Whatever it
is, be questioning these things, but
check this out. Listen to this video
clip. had someone come and brief me who
was in a military uniform, worked for
the United States Army, that was
briefing me on the locations of hybrid
breeding programs where captured aliens
were breeding with humans to create some
hybrid race that that could engage in
intergalactic communication.
Whoa. Gaetz added that humans who were
involved were allegedly abducted. So,
they're saying that they're abducting
um
illegal immigrants.
If I If I remember correctly, let me let
me let her talk for a second. from war
zones. He said, "What they explained is
that the military ran a very secret
program where aliens that were living
were in forced breeding programs with
humans that had been abducted from war
zones, from even the caravans of
migrants." Okay, it's all All right. So,
who is this guy? It is Matt Gaetz and
he's a 43-year-old Republican, member of
the Republican Party, and self-described
libertarian populist. Gaetz is widely
regarded as a proponent of far-right
politics as well as staunch something.
So, he's This guy is in politics.
So, why is all Why is all this stuff
coming out right now? Why are things
coming out to where they're saying,
"Look, aliens are real and the public
deserves the answers."
Why is 2026 like the year when Epstein
files are coming out? Trump says he's
going to disclose aliens. There are
meteors
almost every day in March
and World War III
is going to bring in Armageddon and
Jesus return. Those aren't my words.
That's the words of people in the
military.
Why is all this happening right now and
what is this all about when they're
saying that
there are military secret military
programs that are breeding humans with
aliens. If you watch this channel, if
you know my perspective on this
according to the Bible, these aliens are
not aliens. They're demons in disguise
that are going to deceive humanity on a
worldwide scale. They're going to come
in the name of peace and safety and
they're going to take care of some
things. They're going to, you know, fix
climate change and get rid of pandemics
and be doing lying signs and wonders and
miracles, Revelation says, and that the
whole world will be deceived by means of
those miracles. That the whole world's
going to believe what they see.
These are miracles. This can't be the
devil because he's doing something good.
He's healing people. It has to be
Christ.
But, I started to think a little bit
differently today because psychological
warfare is not always what you expect it
to be. It's like reverse psychology,
right? So,
if Christians are expecting, okay, the
Bible tells us there's going to be three
unclean spirits like frogs that are
going to unite the militaries of the
world together to battle against Christ.
That's prophecy. I believe it. We're
seeing that exact thing happen right
now.
But, there's What if there's a spin on
it? Now, the military is telling us
aliens are real. There's these breeding
programs and there's this this evil
thing happening and some people like
J.D. Vance are saying that these things
are demonic. Um actually
another lady, I can't remember her name
right now, um Marjorie,
also said that aliens are demons. So,
it's starting to become kind of a
mainstream narrative that aliens could
be demons. So, what if
What if the psychological warfare is so
twisted and manipulative that now we are
identifying these
aliens as demons
and when they come, we're all going to
cry out, "These are demons." And and you
know, Trump's shaking hands with an
alien on television. We're like, "These
are demons." And then
a cosmic being of light comes, a
beautiful angel of light,
like the Bible calls Lucifer,
comes and saves us from the demonic
entities.
Now, who are we going to be looking to
as the savior?
Now, everyone, even Christians, are
going to say, "This is Christ. He came
when we almost fell for the deception of
We We They were telling us they were
aliens. The government was telling us
that they were aliens. All these files
were telling us they were aliens, but we
knew
we caught on that they were actually
demons
and we saw Jesus come and wipe them out.
This is Jesus Christ 100% because he
saved us from the demons." And the whole
world bows
to the angel of light. Another deception
wrapped up in a deception. Boom, mind
blown, right? That
You have to really Right when you think
you're like onto something,
it might just take you and blindside
you.
Psychological warfare is crazy. Like I
said, it's uh reverse psychology
oftentimes. You heard about this in
absolutely wild story at a time when we
could be on the verge of some kind of
disclosure about alien life and UFOs
from the White House. They've said this.
Four people who worked in government
programs and knew a whole lot about that
topic have either vanished or been
murdered. What do you think's going on
here?
Well, I don't know exactly. I just know
there are no coincidences in this town.
These folks have disappeared or died
mysteriously and
uh
there's only thing that ties them
together is the fact that they worked on
things that are dealing with um with
with outer space, whether it's UFOs or
nuclear secrets or missiles or what have
you. But, I think we we need we need
full disclosure. Okay, I I want to play
you a sound bite former colleague of
yours, Matt Gaetz,
making some
pretty shocking statements yesterday
about aliens. Take a look.
I had someone come and brief me who was
in a military uniform, worked for the
United States Army, that was briefing me
on the locations of hybrid breeding
programs where captured aliens were
breeding with humans to create some
hybrid race that that could engage in
intergalactic communication. Aliens that
were living were in forced breeding
programs with uh humans that had been
abducted from war zones and from even uh
the caravans of uh of migrants.
All right. I mean, you know, we don't I
don't have the tinfoil hat on just yet,
Congressman, but I'm wondering
you know, kind of how you react to that
because you are connected, you're on the
UFO subcommittee. I mean, I'm just
wondering what you make of that. Have
you heard anything like that?
Um well, I'm still a member of Congress,
so I I can't really comment too much on
what Matt said.
Uh but I I will say this.
>> Wait, seriously? Are you being serious
or is that tongue in cheek?
>> I'm 100% serious.
I mean, 100% serious. I've been briefed
by just about every alphabet agency
there is and um
I'll just tell you this. If they would
release
the things that I've seen,
you would stay up at You You'd be up at
night worrying about or thinking about
this stuff. We just need to disclose it
all. I'm sick of it. This country would
have come unglued, I think, if they
would have heard all that I heard. They
would They would demand answers.
And they And we need to. But, you know,
it's it's never going to get
Unfortunately,
it just keeps getting covered up and
covered up and the people that know are
dying or disappearing, as the case may
be. Wow.
>> And And for the record, I'm not suicidal
and I don't take risks.
So, you guys heard it. Like, this guy's
saying, you know, And this is the thing.
I don't think that
everybody who says this stuff is like in
on it. I don't You know, the Bible says
that the dragon is going to deceive the
entire world. So, I believe that these
guys both really think that this is
real, that these are really alien beings
breeding with humans and trying to
create some super race to communicate
with aliens is crazy, but what I
predict, and I'm not a prophet or
anything, but what I foresee happening,
and I'm going to do a show covering
this, is that I believe they're going to
tell us that aliens have been among us
for thousands of years, that they've
always been here. They've actually
helped us create technology and
different things. And And yeah, there's
some good ones and there's some bad
ones, but they blend in. They're human.
They They They look human and you never
saw them, just like Men in Black, right?
They're working the convenience store
and they've been among us and they
haven't harmed us. And this is how
they're going to disclose because
there won't be a fear of oh, they're
coming. It's just going to be well,
they're among us.
Maybe I married one or whatever.
But the thing is is they are
putting this out there. The more
quote-unquote evidence that they put out
that aliens are real,
the more we will believe it. The less we
will start to believe like well, these
are demonic entities.
Because if they say, oh, we found a
craft or oh, we found a body or oh,
there's breeding
chambers going on, we're going to have
to say, well, that that can't be a
spiritual thing. This has to be a
physical thing.
It's just chaos. It's it's Babylonian
confusion and that's how Satan operates.
Satan operates on creating chaos so that
he can bring the order.
Now, like I said, my my understanding of
how this narrative's going to go down
all this time has been that aliens are
going to come in peace and
you know, maybe Jesus, uh someone that
looks like Jesus walks out of a UFO side
by side with alien greys and says,
you know, all all these things that
people have been seeing along the years
is actually just
angels. You know, these are my angels.
I'm here to save humanity. But now I'm
starting to think that this could be
a reverse psychology psychological
warfare where
we are going to believe that they are
demonic
and Satan or yeah, Satan's going to
appear as Christ and defend
us from the demonic deception. It's a
mind twist, I know.
If this is your first time
ever hearing that the Bible actually
predicts this.
It's in Revelation 16:13 and it says, I
saw three unclean spirits like frogs.
Now, you think about what an alien grey
looks like. If you were to choose
anything in nature to compare what an
alien grey looks like, it would be a
frog. Slimy skin, bulbs on the ends of
your fingers, big eyes, no nose, slit
for a mouth, right? Three unclean
spirits like frogs.
So, these frog-like beings are unclean
spirits and what are they doing?
The next verse says, they are the
spirits of devils working miracles. And
what are they doing? Which go forth unto
the kings of the earth,
the militaries, the leaders,
and of the whole world to gather them to
the battle of the great day of God
Almighty.
The Bible has the answers. Prophecy is
coming true right before our very eyes.
If you have never seen this, I pray that
you will begin to study scriptures,
study the prophecies and
so that you will not be deceived when
this grand deception comes upon the
entire world. It's going to hit us like
an overwhelming surprise. I think it's
coming faster than we can ever imagine.
As you see, this is
this is huge. We went from saying, uh
yeah, we see strange things in the skies
to they are breeding humans with aliens
in cages in the military. So, it's
imminent that they are about to disclose
this stuff and it's very important that
we understand the truth, know the truth.
So, we are actually printing this
brochure, this tract that says, "Top
Secret UFO Disclosure in Bible
Prophecy." We have a link in the in the
bottom for Zeffy. It's it's dependable,
it's reliable, it's free. It's not like
GoFundMe that takes out a portion. And
this
brochure will tell you about the three
unclean spirits prophecy so that we can
easily give somebody this even if
there's no internet. This is analog.
People can read it. It's short, straight
to the point. If you would like to give
to this,
we can print 20,000 of these tracts for
barely over a thousand bucks and we're
over halfway there. We just need your
support to help us get over the hump so
that we can print these as a free
resource to anyone that wants to give
them out. We love you. We thank you. We
cannot do this without you. If you would
like to give to this ministry, you can
do so by going to candidtruth.org. We
got Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, PayPal, and
we got a lot of cool t-shirts on our
website with cool sayings like, uh be
cool, use your brain, the truth will set
you free, love is kind. And if you've
been giving to this ministry, we see
you. We love you. We thank you. And we
always try to give a message back if we
can. We can't on Zelle and Cash App, but
we are telling you thank you right now.
We can't do this without you. And we see
you next time on Candid Truth.